told your producer that there's this  very funny gif that  on the web years ago i was on your show  and i was showing to  um your audience how i was able to be an  oz the great and powerful in a green  screen onesie and how it worked  and i stood up and then just being super  silly  i started humping the air and  there is the funniest gift that maybe  you guys can cut in or show that i  laugh at all the time because your your  face in andy space is the funniest thing  i've  ever seen you're both slowly looking  away  so uncomfortably and i don't know if my  my package or moose knuckle or what's  happening so i'm covering it down there  and i'm just humping the air  yes i just had to share with you how  special that gift is to me  that's i see that in my mind every night  as i try to go to sleep  that's what puts me out